[MUSIC PLAYING]
RON CUIRLE: For those of you
who are in from out of town
or out of country, Target is
a nationwide discount retailer
with approximately 1,845
stores, 350,000 team members,
headquarter locations in
Minneapolis, Minnesota,
in the San Francisco Bay
Area, and several other areas
across the country.
We want to take a moment
and invite you now
to join us at the Target
open house, which is our IoT
and Smart Home showcase
located in the Metreon
on the corner of
4th and Mission,
right here in San Francisco.
Drop by.
Say hi.
And if you are
not familiar again
with what Target or Target
does, our e-commerce website,
target.com, receives a not
insignificant amount of traffic
every month.
It's the fourth most
visited retail website
in the United States.
But our retail presence,
our dot com website,
is just one of our digital
initiatives and part
of our strategy.
Our flagship mobile app allows
you to easily purchase products
from your mobile phone.
Convenient features, like a map,
the product you're looking for,
of where you can
find it in-store,
scan your thing
before you buy it.
Cartwheel offers you
discounts with your Red Card
to quickly check out, get
on with your busy life.
New features, like drive up and
SHIPT provide the convenience
of having your purchases
brought right out to your car
or delivered straight
to your door.
And now that we are through with
the awkward sales and marketing
presentation, you
should recognize
that Target is
essentially retail
that is powered by technology.
And what we want to
do is talk to you
a little bit about
what our technology is
and how we use it at Target.
Take a glance at
our agenda today.
We'll be talking
upfront about what
we want you to get
out of everything,
how we use Target
with the Google Cloud,
our journey thus far,
and some of our journey
into the future, the challenges
that we ran into, our expansion
into Google--
I'm sorry, further
into Google, struggles
that we're still having,
and where we're looking
at for the future.
So as we talk through
all of these things,
there are a few items
that I want you,
that Rachel wants
you to watch for,
these top level
takeaways please.
Number one, organizing your
resources at Google is--
well, can't be
understated how important
it is in order to align those
to how you want to manage cost.
For example, you
might be tempted
to use a single
project within which
to store all of
your applications
or run all of your applications.
That may work for you, if
you're a small mom and pop shop,
or even an enterprise customer.
But we found that it doesn't
work for us because we can't
easily split resources
to align with how
we want to manage that cost.
How you organize your resources,
your org, your folders,
your projects,
your applications,
the products inside
of those projects,
has an enormous impact on
how you look at your bill.
Number two-- organize
all of these resources
to leverage fingerprint
where at all possible.
Those fingerprints should align
to how you want to manage cost.
Fingerprints are going to
survive the test of time,
as your organization changes,
as ownership of an application
changes, as code names
for your projects change.
And three-- please, don't
listen to everything
Google Marketing
has to say about how
they want you to use a product.
Forseti, for example, is
pitched as a security tool,
but we're using it
to enforce the data
integrity for our
application fingerprints.
All right.
In order to start driving
home some of these concepts,
it's going to help,
I think, to know
why we think they're important.
So maybe even important enough
for a 50-minute talk, hm?
We'll find out.
And that's going to require
just a little bit of setup.
Target has, as I just
mentioned, almost 2,000 stores,
distribution centers,
warehouses, data centers,
et cetera, nationwide.
And there are select
aspects at every single one
of those locations,
such that that location
could be considered a,
quote unquote, cloud
environment across the board.
We have infrastructure there.
We have platforms there.
We have applications there.
And due to the
geographic distribution
and the sometimes
limited connectivity,
based on where
those locations are,
each store, each
site I should say,
is treated as a standalone,
isolated cloud environment.
You could call them, for lack
of a better word, mini-clouds,
right?
We also have our own data
centers with similar resources,
there's just a lot more of them.
So maybe those are
not so mini-clouds,
not quite mega clouds.
And then since we're
giving this talk,
it should be pretty obvious
and should surprise no one
that we also use public cloud
providers, such as Google's
cloud.
All right, we'll call
them a mega cloud.
That's fine.
To us-- and this is the most
important part that I can get
across in this slide--
we want to treat all of these
resources the exact same way, e
pluribus unum, if I can, right?
Regardless of the disparity
in the infrastructure,
we want apps runnable everywhere
in the same exact way,
the Target way, not
the store's way,
not the distribution center
way, not Google's way,
but the Target way.
The infrastructure is all
managed slightly differently.
And that means that we
need some sort of platform
in the middle there
between the infrastructure
and the applications in
order to be truly ubiquitous.
So we wrote a thing.
And we call it the Target
Application Platform, or TAP.
The idea is simple.
Given every possible compute
location that Target uses,
the experience of
deploying an application
to any of those locations
should be exactly the same.
Now, if you were at the
keynote this morning,
you heard something from
Google similar, called Anthos.
I think I'm saying that right.
I've frankly only heard it
once or twice this morning.
And TAP, I want you to
know, we want you to know,
just hit its one year
anniversary four days ago
and pretty much kind of
does the same exact thing.
So yay, Target.
OK.
The intricacies of TAP's
design, how we got there,
why we did it, those
are all the contents
of another presentation.
And that YouTube link, should
you want to take a picture
or take a look at
the slide deck later,
will take you to last
year's presentation
on the design of TAP that
we gave at Google Next '18,
in July.
Or if you have
time this evening,
you can attend Dev 217, given
by some of my colleagues
tonight at 5:00 PM.
All right.
The bottom line, regardless, is
that we have clouds everywhere.
And we try to manage and want
to manage what runs there
all in the same exact way.
So what does that mean for
how Target uses Google Cloud?
All right, we have
two primary goals
in leveraging any
cloud provider.
The first-- we want to put the
things that impact our guests--
our customers, that's
our term for guests,
if you're not familiar
with this parlance--
as close to the
guest as possible.
And regardless of the
kinds of workloads
that we could run
there, the things
that make the most
sense at any public
cloud provider, our target.com,
our mobile apps, the things
that you, when you
walk into a store,
experience right then and there.
And the second thing
is that we want
to do it in the most
cost-effective way possible.
And that kind of becomes
a tricky situation
and the point of the talk.
Scale?
Eh, public cloud
providers all scale.
That comes for free.
Google does it better
than everybody else.
I'm biased, anyway.
But even if we weren't using
TAP or any other sort of Target
custom built tool to
deploy our workloads out
to Google, putting stuff
out at a cloud provider,
it's dead easy, right?
But making sure
that we're using it
in the most effective
way possible,
so much harder than we thought.
So much harder than we thought.
You probably do-- in fact,
I'm just going to pause
from the script here.
Who thinks that
it's hard to track
how you're using
your applications out
of Google by a show of hands?
Right?
OK.
Well, [MUMBLES].
Take 20%, nah, 10%.
That's all right.
Boy, that makes me want to ask
why everybody else is here.
[LAUGHTER]
Even if we weren't doing
that, it's super hard.
So why?
Why is it hard?
Some of that is based on
the choices we've made.
And some of that
is frankly based
on the structure of
how Google does things,
of how we've chosen
to use Google,
and of how Google allows
themselves to be used.
We'll talk about both.
RACHEL SHINN: So billing is
a hot topic at Google, right?
We're talking about
money here, and it
gets a lot of visibility.
So gets a lot of questions
with it, questions
from senior leadership,
to our finance
teams, all of the
infrastructure teams
that deploy managed services
on Google Cloud, and then
all the way down to
the application teams
that deploy their apps
on Google Cloud as well.
So you can kind of
break these questions
into two different categories.
Reactive-- so I get the bill,
and I'm like, holy crap,
why is this so big?
What am I spending my money on?
Where are these
services coming from?
Storage, compute, databases,
logging, or something else.
And then there's proactive.
So how do I know if
this is a good number?
Is it too high,
or is it too low?
Or is this just bad?
How do I be more effective in
what I deploy on Google Cloud?
How do I understand
how to be better?
Or how do I understand
how to lower this number?
And so there's one
question that I
want you to think
about every time
we talk about something
up here, every time you're
going to make a decision
on a tool or a service,
and that is really, how do I
provide the most information
that teams can use in order
to make better decisions?
And the next slide here.
Yep.
So we're going to talk a
lot about things that we've
done in the past today, things
that we're currently doing,
and then things that we
want to do in the future.
And I'm going to
pause a few times,
and I'm going to
ask this question.
And based off of
the answer, that's
how we're going to decide
on what we're going to do.
RON CUIRLE: All right.
So there's a long journey to
put stuff out of the cloud.
The larger the enterprise,
likely sometimes
longer the journey is.
But whenever you
start on any journey,
experience, your own
personal experience,
is going to tell you
that there are things
that you can be pretty
sure you're going to run
into along the way, right?
Some of those things you'll know
exactly what to do about it.
Before you even
get there, you know
you'll just have to
deal with the front desk
clerk at the hotel.
And you can't change
their attitude.
And life is just going to suck
for those first few seconds.
So you're either going to
just have to deal with it,
climb over that hurdle,
or go around it somehow.
We can't control the
weather, but we can certainly
take a look at the forecast
and dress appropriately,
or bring an umbrella.
But there are also things on
any journey that trip you up
along the way and knock
you flat on your face
when you're not
expecting them to happen.
When Target first started
moving workloads into Google,
we did not do it in a
big bang kind of way.
It was piecemeal, a
little bit at a time.
We were inching our way
in while migrating out
of another cloud provider.
We knew some of what
we were walking into,
and we very much unknowingly
brought a whole ton of baggage
with us.
Billing was absolutely
not a primary thought,
but it was there, right?
We want to know.
We want to be able
to control it.
But it wasn't a primitive.
It wasn't considered
something that was key
when we started this journey.
So this piecemeal
method, unfortunately,
led us to making some
decisions and choices that
made sense at the
time, that later turned
into the kinds of things that
you trip over because you
didn't see it in
the path and makes
you fall flat on your face.
And some of those things made
sense at the previous provider,
like a singular project.
It made sense there, doesn't
make sense here to us.
At Google, all of
a sudden, we were
thrust into a situation
where we had to give better
information to our developers.
And we weren't well
equipped to do it.
Everything's a
journey, though, right?
You've got missteps.
You've got backtracks.
You've got bridge building.
It's par for the course.
So let's talk about
some of the things
we saw before we ever
started this migration.
Let's call them big rocks.
These are the things you know
you're going to run into.
At Target, we're
absolutely not going
to be able to change the
organizational structure
of our company from
the ground up to suit
what is possible at a
given cloud provider.
So we need a way to
identify a resource
and have that reportable
at every level of the org.
That rock, we kind of
chose to ignore going in,
even though we
knew it was there.
We didn't treat
it as a primitive.
Don't make that same choice
that we made, please.
Secondarily, while
most companies actually
split up their
bill and pass that
along to various parts
of their organization
either for direct payment or
internal transfer of funds,
Target takes that
bill, splits it up,
and shows every level
of our organization
what they've spent.
But we don't expect any
payment in return for that.
One part of the org is
responsible for paying
all infrastructure costs
associated with that provider.
And that part alone is
responsible for the cost
control associated
with that bill.
So we all share responsibility.
In summary here, we all
share responsibility
in contributing to that
bill, but only one party
is accountable to
its management.
That can be a problem.
Imagine you're an
application team.
And you're sitting
there, and people
are telling you, spend less.
Why do you care?
You are neither accountable, it
doesn't impact you financially,
it potentially impacts
you technologically
to change the way that you're
running your application.
Why do you care?
We'll talk more about
that a little bit later.
But just keep in mind
that we have no carrot
or stick to change a team's
decisions about how they
use their resources at Google.
And lastly, that
last bullet point--
bring your own Kubernetes.
We knew from the
very, very beginning
that we would not be using GKE,
but bringing our own Kubernetes
clusters to Google Cloud.
If you're familiar with
Kubernetes, either older
versions of GKE or some of
the more recent versions
of Kubernetes Native,
you know that the idea
of shared resources is great
from a compute efficiency
point of view.
But tracking who used what
when can be kind of hard.
So we knew upfront we
were going to need a way
to apportion our
Kubernetes VM bill, such
that we knew how a
namespace was being used
in a relatively accurate way.
All right.
So these are the
things that weren't
going to change when we moved
our workloads to Google.
We still have to know how we're
going to climb over these rocks
and achieve what
we want to achieve.
It turns out that every
big cloud provider also
has their own big rocks that
you absolutely can't change.
At Google, one of
those is labels.
Remember, we want the holy grail
of enabling these teams to make
their own better decisions.
Labeling, very
popular way, not new,
to add more meta information
to your resources.
And they even end up
in billing exports
which, if you spend a lot of
time in them, is so fantastic.
You've got attributions
to send back.
Life is great.
But there are products,
like Stackdriver Logging,
that records
information coming in
from resources, like HTTP load
balancers, that can be labeled.
But the resulting logs from
those resources cannot be
apportioned, even though they
have their own cost associated
with them.
For example, in this screenshot,
cloud HTTP load balancers,
that particular resource, the
log that is load balancer logs,
cannot be labeled.
But remember, we also
have one project up front.
All of our applications are
sharing this log source.
How do I find out that
application A is largely
responsible for 50 or more
percent of all of the costs
going in there and give that
team accurate show back?
Help them manage
themselves, right?
Remember, we started
with that single project,
and we just kept moving
new applications in.
So the more apps we had,
the harder it became.
And now, let's talk about
some of the tripping stones.
All right.
I think that they came in three
different kinds of categories.
First, there are
things that we knew
we'd be creating tech debt for,
if we did it a certain way.
But we did it anyway,
thinking to ourselves,
we'll deal with it later.
OK, now I want a show of hands.
Who does that all the time?
Thank you.
RACHEL SHINN: Everybody.
RON CUIRLE: Thank you.
You are lying if you
do not raise your hand.
That's fine.
The second category is
that we couldn't do it
the way that we assumed
we could because of either
a misunderstanding, or
some reason or another,
about our interpretation
of the docs,
or the way the docs were
written, or who knows what?
And the third category is that
we didn't know we could do it,
or we didn't know that
we had to do it in order
to get that piece
of information.
So let's talk about
some of those items.
At our previous cloud
provider, for example,
we had established a
naming convention such
that an app and component
combo would uniquely
identify the application
utilizing a resource.
So that would even address
certain security startup
problems, like let's make
sure that if you are not
a registered application
or a registered component,
we're not going to allow you
to read these secrets out
of our platform.
We're not going to allow you
to read these key value pairs.
to register your services.
And because-- oh.
Actually, let me back up just
one moment and give an example.
Think about application
and component.
Think about price
as an application.
And within price, we
might have an API.
We might have a Redis
component of these things.
They all roll up to
this price application,
but everything's got
their own component.
This is legacy.
This is previous cloud provider.
But did you know that
application teams love
code names for what they write?
OK, at least I see some smiles.
This is good.
And what happens when
those code names change?
What happens when a new
leader comes in and says,
I don't want to own
that product anymore.
Give it to so-and-so.
All of a sudden, the
application still exists.
The product still exists.
The components may change,
but it no longer rolls up
to the same portion
of the organization.
And that's not good.
That's not good for
tracking cost over time.
The first apps that
we put out at Google
only used compute and
network resources.
It's important to know,
because maybe this is partly
defensive to say, we kind
of knew it might happen,
but that's all right.
There was no BigQuery.
There was no Stackdriver.
There was no anything,
except compute and network.
Because remember, we
wanted an agnostic way
to be able to use
those primitives
that every public cloud
provider offered in order
to have our platform be agnostic
and deployable to any location.
Putting ourselves
into a single project
totally made sense
at the time, but how
do you divvy up those things?
RACHEL SHINN: Alrighty.
So some of the
challenges that we faced.
This is just a basic
output of our billing data
flow looks like.
And it should look
pretty similar, right?
You go into the Cloud console
under the Billing section,
and you hit Export My Data.
It all goes into a Google
Cloud Storage bucket.
And then it gets
sent into BigQuery.
From there, we created
a handful of views
that we could actually visualize
this data in a different tool.
And the two tools
that we primarily used
were Data Studio and Grafana.
And just for reference, Data
Studio is a Google product,
but it is not a
Google Cloud product.
However, it is very
easy to integrate
the data between the two.
And then Grafana is just
another visualization tool
that Target uses as part of
our measurement platform.
So this is what the billing
data flow looks like.
Two big caveats that
I want to call out
is that, first, our teams don't
have access to actually go
into the Cloud console.
They don't have those
[INAUDIBLE] permissions.
We use other tools to actually
deploy such a Spinnaker.
Or for teams that are
deploying containers,
you can just directly
from the command line.
So that kind of posed a problem
when we wanted to use labels,
right?
Because labels was an option,
but it wasn't enforced.
It wasn't regulated.
So therefore, teams
just didn't do it.
So that was the first
challenge that we really
needed to figure
out is, how do we
go through and apply
those labels when teams
aren't doing it themselves?
So our short-term
solution was to write
a script that retroactively
goes in a couple of times a day
and looks at all the new
instances that are created,
grabs the instance
name, and then
applies that name as a label
under a key value pair.
So we had the key
as something like,
finance tag or application.
And then the actual
value of that would
be the actual instance name.
So first caveat.
Second caveat is-- so I'm
forgetting some of my notes
here.
Ahem.
Let's move on.
So this is an example of
the Data Studio dashboard
that we had initially created.
As you can see, this is
the price application
that Ron mentioned
a little bit ago.
And you can see the
components here--
api, redis, solr, cassandra.
The actual design is not what
I really want to talk about.
It's not the meat of
this presentation.
How we filter, how we
group everything together
is what is important here.
So we use a feature that is
within Data Studio itself,
called filtering.
And since it is not
coming from BigQuery,
all of these filters that
we apply are all manual.
So for each
application team that's
deploying into Google Cloud,
we created a new dashboard
for them.
We created a new
filter for them.
And so as you can imagine,
as our teams grow,
as the applications
grow in Google,
it gets really
cumbersome because,
for the initial migration, the
40 or so applications that we
had, it was more of like
a mental list in Ron
and I's mind.
We know the Price
Application team.
We know who owns it
at a broader level.
But when you start having
teams that change ownership,
or they start
changing code names--
and for reference,
everybody loves
to put the word "red" in every
of the code names we have.
So you've got 20 red somewhere.
It gets really cumbersome.
It gets really manual.
It's something that can't
scale with all of our apps.
Now, another problem.
This is just for teams
that are directly
deploying on virtual machines.
Ron mentioned that we brought
our own Kubernetes clusters.
And roughly, about half
of the compute that we use
are actually
Kubernetes clusters.
And those Kubernetes
clusters are essentially
virtual machines in
compute engine, right?
So that label that's
getting applied to them,
they're all getting tagged
as Kubernetes Master,
or Kubernetes Node.
And when we need to actually go
down and break down that usage
and see who's using
what, it's something
that we can't do
with Data Studio.
So that leads us to a
different dashboard.
Now, this is a tool
called Grafana,
which I mentioned before as part
of Target's measurement stack.
And so what we ended
up doing is writing
an API that goes in and
grabs the total number of CPU
and memory requests
per namespace
and assigns a relative
cost, compared
to the total number of CPU
memory requests per cluster.
And we got the total cost of
the cluster from those labels
that we were using, since it's
still getting tagged here.
Now, this dashboard and the one
that I just had before roughly
show the same thing--
the breakdown per application
over a period of time,
and per environment.
We've got both our test
project and production project,
as well.
Now, what if you're
an application team
and you're deploying
both containers
and virtual machines?
One of the questions that
I always got was, well,
can you just tell me one number?
Like, I don't want to have to
go to two different places.
Like, I know it's
super simple, right?
And so we did the most high
tech thing we could think of,
and we sent all of this data
into an Excel spreadsheet,
on a manual basis,
on a weekly basis.
And just so you know, I still
get asked for the spreadsheet
today.
You know, we did
this two years ago.
So just to recap-- all
of our virtual machines
that were getting deployed were
getting tagged with labels.
And that was going
into Data Studio.
All of our Kubernetes
deployments,
our container deployments, were
getting tagged using that API
and breaking down by namespace.
And that was going into
another visualization tool,
called Grafana.
And since we split
the two up, we
had to marry them back together
in this Excel spreadsheet.
That alone is a
number of problems
that I don't even
want to get into.
And I'm sure you can
guess what those are.
But at this point, we're
just tagging compute, right?
I mean, granted, compute
is a huge percentage of our
build-- like 80% or
90% at this point.
But we're largely
ignoring every other cost.
I mean, we had a handful
of cloud storage buckets.
We had a handful of
cloud SQL instances.
And for both of those
cases, those things
can be labeled and tagged.
And we were just ignoring them.
We labeled it as an
overhead cost and moved on.
But then we had all
these other things, too,
like the Stackdriver monitoring
and then certain networking
costs that can't be tied
back to an instance.
And then one last problem
is that this is just
a test project and a
production project.
Granted, they were the
two largest projects
within our entire org,
but we had a handful
of other projects that
were proof of concepts
or for testing reasons
that we're also ignoring.
So this initial
migration into the Google
Cloud, again, like I said,
it was about 40 or so
applications.
We were tagging most
of what we could.
But let's think back
to that first question
that I asked everybody, right?
Does this provide information
that teams can use in order
to make better decisions?
Can I look at one
of these dashboards
and say, I know that's a good
number, or I know that's bad,
or I know that's too high,
or I know where my waste is?
And the answer is still, no.
RON CUIRLE: All right.
I want to mention
briefly something
that Rachel
mentioned, and that's
all of the
un-allocable costs that
came out of our first pass.
She said that they
have a tendency
to just kind of be dismissed,
or assigned to the platform team
incorrectly, namely
our teams, such
that it looks like we are
10% of our entire total bill.
When in fact, we're
probably 1% or less.
We just have everything
that isn't allocable.
All right.
Anyway, thus far in
our journey, Target
had chosen to run only
non-commerce workloads related
to target.com at Google.
Some of that was in support
of mobile, some not.
These workloads are all about
the public information that's
available on our website.
You go to the website, you
browse, you see a price,
you see an item, those are API
endpoints that is not secret.
There's not a ton of security
that we need to put out there
around those kinds of controls.
But that security?
Relatively simple,
in comparison to what
we were about to undertake.
So in July of 2018, we started
to migrate our commerce
workloads to Google Cloud.
And that, of course, came
with one huge, new big rock--
regulatory compliance.
Anybody?
OK, we've got-- yes, this
is a problem, definitely
from security.
So we knew we needed
to look at organizing
our resources a
little bit better,
to be able to manage that
regulatory compliance easier.
And we had a chance
to apply at least some
of what we had done to fix some
of those pesky little tripping
stones that we had tripped
on-- project naming
conventions, application
code names, and more.
So let's take a look.
Get out your phones.
This is the one that you want
to take a picture of, right?
And the second or third
to last slide as well.
This is from our colleagues that
are presenting Networking 200,
A Year In GCP Networking.
Unfortunately, that talk
is happening right now--
please don't get up and leave--
in another room.
But similar to the talk
that is happening right now,
the same colleagues are giving
a talk called Architecture 208,
70 Days PCI Compliance to
Production With a Hybrid Cloud.
That's right, 70 business
days using this design
to get all of our commerce
workloads out there.
And one of our presenters is
sitting here in the front row
with a big, wide smile,
going tee, hee, hee.
All right.
Let's talk about some
of the lessons here.
For our purposes
today, I want to be
able to call out some huge
benefits of this design that
translate into better
tracking, better billing costs.
First, we learned
that leveraging
every available capability of
a shared VPC is a no-brainer.
One of those capabilities
is putting resources
in one project within
an organization,
but allowing
communication to happen
between the projects using a
shared subnet, for example.
Define all the
subnets in one area,
but define the actual
resources in each
of the compute projects,
or in their own project.
I should refer to the notes.
Specifically, I say the subnets
there and the compute engine
resources in their own projects.
So what does this do?
Now, when a team spins
up a compute resource,
it's in a project assigned to
that team and only that team.
Yay.
But Rachel's going to talk
in a little bit about how
that's still a problem.
Number two, platform components
that were previously getting
all of the un-allocable costs.
Look, we've got our
own project now,
and we get treated just like
every application that's
out there.
So that's good.
And we get project level
IAM all of a sudden
that we didn't have
before, that we
had to build our own security
around, and was just nasty.
Third, app teams can consume
now Google-specific services.
And their usage gets
attached directly
to that project that's
allocable to that team.
It doesn't matter that
they're using something that
can't be tagged anymore, right?
Maybe.
Everything in the
project belongs to them,
but maybe it still matters
that we can't tag it.
Four-- quota management.
Oh, wow.
I'm sure our partners at
Google were very, very
happy to stop getting
our phone calls about,
we need another 2,000 instances
raised in our production
environment, or give
us another 10,000 this,
or we need more load balancers.
Who that knows what?
But regardless, there
is still a problem here.
Every application
team could be putting
more than just their application
into a particular project.
Rachel's going to
talk about that.
We need some sort of
better identification.
So back to our second
highlight, or second takeaway,
from the top of the slide deck--
lowest common denominator.
So introducing the configuration
item ID, yay, ITIL users.
Everybody who follows
ITIL, life is great.
It's an eight-digit
unique number
across all of Target's
business units.
And you remember
at the beginning
when we were talking
about TAP, the goal of tap
is to deploy things the
Target way across our fleet.
It is not the store's
way, not the Google Cloud
way, the Target way.
CIs?
A target identifier.
Lovely.
They are our lowest
common denominator.
And what if we could apply
them to everything at Google?
Great idea, right?
Except it's not a new idea.
A lot of you in the room
are going, yeah, yeah.
We do this already.
This is fine.
No big deal.
But our additional challenge
is if an application team
has no financial responsibility
to tag their stuff,
or voluntarily tag
their resources,
how do we leverage
tech to do it for us?
How do we enforce, or at least
manage, the data consistency?
How can we ensure
complete coverage of all
of those resources at Google?
Hello Cloud Functions. ,
Again maybe not a new idea.
We ask our teams to
label their resources.
But if they mess it up, if
they screw it up, that's OK.
We have Cloud Functions
in place for the launch
of every compute resource.
That allows for the
sanitation and standardization
of the configuration item data.
If teams don't supply
a CI at all, that's OK.
What do we do?
Well, if we really
care to, we could
have that Cloud Function prevent
that instance from starting up,
and just say, mm!
Our security teams really
like this idea, by the way.
But since it's really about
making it easy for app teams
to consume, that seemed
a little extreme.
So how do we track this?
Hello, Forseti.
It's pitched as a security tool.
But at its base, if you're
not familiar with it,
it's just about
finding deviations
from a desired standard.
We run reports to identify
things that can have labels,
but don't, things that have
a misconstrued label, that
indicate that we need
to have better logic
inside of our functions.
Notification is manual for
now, but there's nothing
stopping us from
spending some time
and taking our best guess at who
actually owns that application
and automating a report to
be sent back out to them.
We also have some
pretty crazy ideas
about making that backend
more robust and automated that
involve Pub/Sub, that involve
Stackdriver monitoring, that
involve cloud tasks and
even machine learning
to help us be even smarter
about these decisions.
While you're here this
week, keep a close eye
on alphas, betas,
GAs being announced.
I've been scrubbed from
talking about the programs
that we use, but there are
exciting things on the horizon
that will make some
of the challenges
that we're talking
about and mentioned
in the last few slides all
of a sudden very, very easy.
RACHEL SHINN: Alrighty.
So we've got these
configuration items
that we're now applying to
everything in Google Cloud.
Ron and I are
thrilled, because that
means the end of all that
manual filtering that we
had to do in Data Studio.
And instead, you see a dashboard
like this where, at the top,
you can dropdown and choose your
specific configuration item,
or perhaps a cluster
of configuration items
that apply to your application.
And you can also dropdown and
select your specific project
that you want to see.
And you can see all of the
data that you could see before.
In this case for
showing compute,
it's also tagging cloud storage.
It's taking cloud SQL.
Everything that can be
tagged is getting tagged.
Yay, right?
No, if it's not what happened.
So some teams took
our advice, and they
started tagging
different components
with each different CI
or configuration item.
Other teams just kept on doing
what they were doing before.
And they used the same
configuration item
across all of the components
in their application.
Other teams, who managed
multiple applications,
used one configuration item
across multiple applications.
So this didn't work, right?
We wanted to be able to break
down our costs even further.
We wanted to be able to
allocate where the spending was
coming down, even further.
But that didn't really happen.
And again, we still
don't really have
a way of providing
real time increases
and decreases, as
teams make updates
to their infrastructure,
which is something that
has been on the back
of our minds, something
we wanted to do, but we still
hadn't quite figured out.
So we kept our old dashboards.
We kept all of the
manual filtering,
even after we kept growing
in our footprint at Google.
I mean, we started with
those additional 40 apps,
and we've grown beyond that now.
And we still have
these manual filters.
Although, I guess,
the nice thing
is that once you
build them, you're
done where you don't have
to go in and change them
or anything like
that, hopefully,
and assuming teams don't change
their names or ownerships.
But if you look
at this dashboard,
it's slightly different than the
one that I showed you before.
And that's because we edited
our filters just slightly.
So we showed beyond
application dash component.
At this point, we're
showing different versions
of components.
You can see here,
for price, their API,
they've got a version
1, and version 2.
You can also see that
they're in multiple regions.
So we've got breakdowns
by region, as well.
And essentially, these are
the instance groups that
are getting deployed, right?
I mean, initially, we we're
grabbing the instance name.
And that's where that
label comes from.
But at this point, we're able
to group by instance group now.
And most of our apps use
instance groups to deploy,
rather than just deploying
a single instance at a time.
RON CUIRLE: Can you talk
about why that's important,
before you move on?
RACHEL SHINN: Why?
RON CUIRLE: All of this is if
a team wants more information
to make better decisions.
RACHEL SHINN: Yes.
RON CUIRLE: How
are they ever going
to know that version
2 of an application
is performing better and using
less money than version 1,
if we don't have this?
RACHEL SHINN: And that's what
these dashboards did, right?
So you can see that they've
got multiple versions deployed.
And their versions might
be different, right?
They make an update
to their code,
they make a different
modification or something,
and they redeploy.
And we can monitor now.
We can see the changes.
We can see the disparencies
between the two,
and they can decide
which one's better.
So where does that
leave us, right?
Let's think back to
that initial question.
Does this provide
enough information
that teams can use to make
those better decisions?
The answer's still, no.
Unfortunately, right?
We're not providing
enough information,
/ it seems like cost data just
isn't cutting it at this point.
And so as we looked to expanding
these dashboards beyond Google
Cloud, we wanted
to integrate all
of our other platforms
as well, potentially all
of our managed services.
We really had to figure out
why the answer to that question
kept being no.
And that's where we come up with
different kinds of information,
specifically capacity
and efficiency.
So we're going
through, we're tagging
all of this other
information, right?
We're looking at capacity--
the total number of VMs
that I've got deployed.
And we're looking at efficiency.
So of those 100 VMs that I
might have just deployed,
what am I actually using?
Am I at 5% utilization?
Am I at 10%?
And those numbers are what we
can start conversations with.
And obviously, you're all
familiar-- like, for capacity,
I closely relate it to cost too.
Because I spin up 100 VMs.
That's my total capacity.
That's total allocated number
of resources that I've got.
And I pay for that, right?
I pay for what
I've spun up, and I
don't pay for what I
actually use of that.
So it's really
important when we're
talking about managing costs
and eliminating operating costs
and everything like
that, because that starts
that conversation
with those app teams,
so that we can make
them more, not reliable,
but make them more cognizant
of what their spending is.
And again, like
I said, we really
wanted to expand
our cost dashboards
across all of our platforms.
And so now, by combining the
three kinds of information,
we can.
And we can also target our
managed services, as well.
And so when I say
managed services,
we've got a couple of different
infrastructure teams that
provide services for
application teams to use,
such as database tools,
or measurement tools.
And historically,
every database cost
was attributed back
to the database team,
even though a bunch
of application teams
were using those databases.
And so now what we can
do with this information
is actually tie it
back to the application
team that's using it.
So where does that
leave us going forward?
This is a pretty new initiative
at Target and something
that we're still building out.
But essentially, what we want
to do is capture allocation,
utilization, and cost data
all together-- all of it,
it's a ton of data--
and at the deepest
level that we can.
So for some of our
platforms, it's
all the way down to an
individual host or server.
Others, not so much.
It just really depends
on the platform.
But we're going to
export that data.
We're going to
start publishing it
so that teams can
actually see it.
But before, it was just for
infrastructure teams, right?
I could go in and
see what my platform,
like the utilization of it.
But I didn't share that
with the application
teams using my platform.
And so that was really a
change of how we did things.
So we're exporting all this
data, either via Kafka topics,
or an API.
We're still kind of
understanding and identifying
what the best practices
for long term,
especially as some
of our platforms
are a little bit more modern.
And then some of them
are a little bit legacy
in our data centers.
So we really just need to
figure out what the best way is.
And then we're ingesting all
of that data in a single place.
And it's all getting aggregated
on our big data platform, which
does live in our data centers.
We're working with
our data science teams
to build a couple of views
that we're not sending all
of that data somewhere else.
We're just sending what we
need, and we're displaying it
on a single dashboard that you
can export that data into a CSV
if you need it to get
that fine level detail.
But essentially, this dashboard,
if I were an application team,
I can go and say, here's
my configuration item,
or here's my application.
And I can everywhere
that it's deployed.
I can see the total
allocated resources
that I've got for
that configuration
item, or for my
component, for my app.
I can see the actual CPU and
memory utilization of that.
And then I can see, if we can
provide it, attributable cost.
So if any of you
are familiar, it's
really hard to determine
specific costs for apps that
are deployed in data centers.
It's really easy for
Google, because I
get a bill every month.
But for data centers,
it's not the case.
So favorite question-- does
this provide information?
Can a team go into
this dashboard,
see information, and make a
decision based off of that?
And finally, we think the
answer is, yes, we hope so.
Again like I said,
we're still kind
of building out this
whole dashboard and what
it looks like.
But we have been
sending it out to teams,
and it's been providing a
lot of great results already.
And it really helps us
start those conversations
with teams that might
be over-subscribing,
or they might be over-allocating
resources to themselves,
and they're not using it.
And so it's just a way for
us to be a little bit better
in efficiency and capacity.
So just to recap--
we talked about how
we organize things
and why it didn't work for us.
And then we talked about how
we did it differently, right?
And don't want you to be
afraid of changing the way
that things were,
assuming you can.
We talked about the
common denominator,
that's configuration item.
It didn't work for us
great in Google Cloud,
but it's something that was
a standard across Target.
And so if you were
to go and request
new resources for something
in our data centers,
like you are required to enter
in that configuration item.
That is a standard practice
across all of our platforms
now.
And so teams know what it is.
They know it.
They are expecting it.
They know they need to do it.
And then the products--
Forseti and Cloud Functions.
They're not used for billing.
They weren't
marketed for billing,
but we're using them
for that anyways,
because we're making it work
for what we needed it to do.
RON CUIRLE: Ubiquitous
compute platforms
require a ubiquitous
billing platform.
RACHEL SHINN: Yes.
Yes.
Ron mentioned the Target
application, or TAP, right?
The idea was that
regardless of where
you're deploying
your application,
you go to one spot.
And everything you
need is right there.
That's the same
approach that we wanted
to take with billing too, right?
Just you go to one
spot, everything
is there that you need.
You don't need anything else.
And with that, we'd
just love to thank you.
RON CUIRLE: Thank you.
RACHEL SHINN: It's exciting.
Yeah.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]